we're waiting for a remain in mexico i
believe we have that decision in
shannon brem do you are you there
yes okay so this looks like and this is
a long one too but we're getting through
this it looks like the chief justice
john roberts and justice cavanaugh
joined with the liberal three justices
for a 5-4 decision that's in favor of
the byte administration at least for now
again this one is a little bit
complicated but they say essentially the
government's recision of that remain in
mexico policy did not violate
federal law but they say this october
29th memorandum they took two bites at
trying to get rid of this remain in
mexico didn't constitute final agency
action so they say they're reversing the
court of appeals which had decided
against the biden administration but
sending this case back down for further
proceedings so this is a win at first
blush at first read overview here for
the bind administration that has been
trying to get rid of remain in mexico
we'll see if this is the final death
note on that policy but for now it looks
like a 5-4 decision that should make the
white house happy after a week where
they've had a real buffeting and a brush
back of everything they've been trying
to do in their policies this looks like
the final case of the term is going to
be one that will make the white house
happy we're gonna keep reading okay you
keep reading and let's bring in texas
congressman henry cuellar who has been
gracious enough to join us this morning
uh we we're just getting this in it
looks like a 5'4 decision maybe just
like perhaps on a technicality i'm not
exactly sure yet and you are looking at
this too
what were you hoping to see happen here
congressman
you know i want to make sure we have
policies in place i can treat the
migrants with respect and dignity but at
the same time
have repercussions and that we follow
the laws because otherwise we're going
to continue to have record number of
migrants coming into the united states
and a lot of them are going to be
releasing our streets so again i want to
treat it with respect but the policies
have to be caliber in such a way
that it doesn't encourage more people to
come into the united states
for you for your area for your
neighborhood your district um
the idea of remaining in mexico was that
let's try to have a process here not
swamp the border not swamp the border
patrol let's have them remain in mexico
the bite administration twice tried to
get rid of it did you ever advise them
that that was a bad decision
yeah you know my position has been uh
that uh in this case if you have them
remain in mexico and they have access to
an attorney they want to to come and
present their case uh and they're
in a safe situation then we ought to do
that because otherwise you have so many
people that come in come into the united
states uh and a lot of them are given
false hope because if you have a hundred
people
only 10 to 12 percent are going to be
given asylum only 10 to 12 percent are
going to be given asylum so why are we
letting 100 percent well we should be
allowing only 10 to 12 percent of those
people come into the united states
president biden has been away for four
days or five days at nato important
meeting but there's been a lot of things
happening back home
and there's the roe v wade decision
there's the fact that inflation and gas
prices continue
uh crime across the border
excuse me across the country is a really
big issue
the border is a major issue griff
jenkins has been there for six days he's
counted nine thousand people came across
do you think that biden will ever turn
his attention
to the border in a serious way before
the midterms
yeah you know and i feel uh bad for the
president because there's so many issues
happening in the united states
domestically and across the world uh
dealing with russia and china so i mean
i feel you know bad for him but at the
same time you know there are people uh
that can implement uh the laws that we
have in the books already to make sure
that there's repercussions because
otherwise when we finish this fiscal
year which will be on september 30th we
are going to have record number of
people coming into the united states uh
and and this is why certain policies
like title 42 are important to keep in
place uh what we look at the situation
at the border again if there's no
repercussions or people are returned
under title 8 or title 42 they're going
to keep coming into the united states in
large large numbers congressman henry
cuellar thank you for your time today
sir
thank you so much hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now